(uptempo music)
- [Narrator] You probably remember this
hilarious moment from
When Harry Met Sally.
- Then she tells you her stories,
you tell her your stories.
- [Narrator] Well, this
ridiculous rom-com scene
is indicative of a real and
very serious sport, which,
believe it or not, introduced
society to sport betting.
Competitive walking, better know to some
as pedestrianism, started in the 1800s.
Aristocrats at that time had footmen
whose job was to carry messages
from one aristocrat to another.
It was only a matter of
time until the aristocrats
started making wagers on
whose footman was faster.
Thus, the birth of sport
betting as we know it.
(cheering)
(dramatic music)
Competitive walking grew
into a real sporting event,
and reached its peak
in the 1870s and 1880s,
when spectators would show up in
Super Bowl-like masses to see
people walk competitively.
They even filled up the
original Madison Square Garden.
Wow.
Sometimes races would last up to six days
and the atmosphere was
almost festival-like.
Brass bands played,
vendors sold pickled eggs,
maybe even some roasted chestnuts.
Yum.
The competitions drew everyone,
from celebrities to
politicians, even regular folk.
Champagne, of all things, was
the drink of choice for walkers.
They thought it was a stimulant,
and, as one would, they
drank it by the bottle.
And, guess what, it kinda worked.
One guy walked 136 miles in just 34 hours.
Bottoms up.